number one here the daily wire reports
kenosha prosecutors have dropped the sex
assault charges against jacob blake
following a plea agreement um blake
pleaded guilty now jacob blake of course
he was the uh
he's the the man in kenosha who was
shot by police officers as he was as
police officers were called to the scene
he was allegedly uh harassing
um a woman who also had accused him of
of of raping her
and he had a knife he assaulted the cops
he tried to get into a car
not his car he tried to get into the
woman's car uh with his kids in there
they tried to stop him they told him to
stop
he reached into the car and then they
shot so that was the recap on that
but he had these sex assault charges
again the woman
whose house he was at had accused him of
sexual assault
now prosecutors are dropping those
charges
as part of a plea agreement right blake
pleaded guilty to two counts of
disorderly conduct in order to get the
third degree sexual assault charge
dropped
blake told judge brian schroeder
honestly your honor
though i plead guilty to this i don't
consider myself to be guilty i pretty
much took this opportunity to get to see
my children quicker
blake also said he did not sexually
assault the woman making the allegations
against him blake's attorney
said dropping the charge meant
prosecutors were acknowledging that
ultimately the state could not prove it
in court
walworth county district attorney zeke
weidenfeld
told the outlet that the sexual assault
charge was dropped in part because the
accuser refused to cooperate with
prosecution
yeah well of course she refused to
cooperate
and the fact that they didn't that they
didn't have evidence to prove in court
does not at all mean it didn't happen
these are very we have to keep
remember this these are extremely
credible charges against jacob blake
the reason why they're extremely
credible is because
his accuser called police the morning
that this incident happened she said
that jacob blake
broke into her window at like 6 a.m on
like a sunday morning
and walked into a room where she was
sleeping and sexually assaulted her
and then stole her keys her car and her
credit card and left
she she called 9-1-1 and she was
trembling and crying she was still in
her you know in her nightgown
and they came and they saw her there
crying and and
obviously traumatized um
i would call that an extremely credible
accusation this is this isn't one of
those accusations somebody comes out of
the woodwork
woodwork you know 30 years later this is
at the moment calling police this is
what happened to me
uh she's not cooperating okay of course
she's not cooperating
her alleged abuser who by the way she
says
has been abusing her for years not just
that one time
for years she said um and he's been
lionized
canonized by the media by the democrat
party
the potential new president of the
united states
went and met with jacob blake's family
and jacob blake himself
and was singing his praises afterwards
so all of the most powerful people
matt put yourself in this woman's
position
assuming that her allegations are true
which i absolutely believe her
believe all women no we don't believe
all women i believe this woman because
the allegations are credible
put yourself in her position you are
viciously assaulted by this man
and now and and then a few months later
he comes steals your keys
you're trying to protect him from you
know your kids uh
gets himself shot in the after
assaulting police
and now all the most powerful voices in
society are coming to his defense and
saying he's a great guy
he's a great father even
what is she supposed to do she comes out
and
tries to get this guy locked away
um she's gonna be worried for her own
safety she's gonna be worried about uh
about you know being
dragged through the mud so you you can
definitely see where she's coming from
there
but where are the feminists on this
this this is something where you know
you would think feminists would come out
and come to this woman's
defense i haven't heard anything
and we have seen this whether it's with
jacob blake george floyd
you know there have been at least three
or four cases just in the last few
months
of blm making martyrs and heroes and
and canonizing uh men who have
abused women in horrible ways
and those women are silenced nobody
talks about them nobody cares about them
feminists not coming to their defense
because feminists are of course
disingenuous phonies in almost every
single
case well i hope you enjoyed that clip
from the matt walsh show if you did
go ahead and hit that subscribe button
right down there so you can stay up to
date on all of our future content